[Music]
plans for the united kingdom's
biggest theme park
face huge setback because of tiny
spiders what is their biggest theme park
wait what's your biggest theme park
right now
oh yeah did they have pollock's land
bullets
every right buckingham palace huh
every one of the rides work another
right to work you just go in like ah
bollocks
that's what we're here for and
[ __ ] headland
they just get wasted and like oh [ __ ]
welcome to [ __ ] in hell
all right anyway do they have a harry
potter world over there i don't think so
ironic as [ __ ] isn't it that would
probably kill over the whole place is
probably just harry potter
do you know how shitty london is oh they
don't have harry potter world we have
like two of them and they they have like
a train station with just a fake wall
that's all they got so [ __ ] up i was
at that it's king's cross station yeah
that's where they filmed the harry
potter thing got a fake wall do they
have platform nine and three quarters
there they do they put like a nine and
three quarters they did that's so but
that's all they get
totally done all right well a tiny
spider has created a setback for a 3.5
billion pound uk theme park he's
laughing at that it's a little spider
it's a little tiny cute little spider
you can burn that
it's tom holland i feel like they have
more spiders over there
i'm pretty sure it's like an educated
guess but i don't know they were brought
over to the americas by christopher
columbus the way you said it was like
you have insider information
i have no interest in spiderman it's
just
um so after uh both the bbc and itv were
uh major partners with this theme park
and they both pulled out of the plans
because of this spider incident that joe
is still laughing about
the london resort which is set to open
uh in kent has planned to have both
broadcasters on board so it could
feature rides inspired by hit shows
such mitered by what a show such as
doctor who sherlock and thunderbirds
what are that what kind of rides are the
underbirds the freaking puppet dudes
dude sherlock the ride is like i'm
asleep already bro i'm sure what would
it be maybe it's like an escape room
where you have to like figure out oh
it'll be cool
oh like an escape room would be kind of
i like the benedict coming back sherlock
i just picture you're on like one of
those disney roller coasters and in
every room he's got a magnifying glass
to his eye looking at you yeah that's
this is what else they got they're a lot
guy yeah
i don't know what else they got nobody
else watched ben into cumberbatch
sherlock i hear it's good i heard it's
good too i thought it was dope how many
goddamn sherlocks are gonna be i just a
lot that was the last one
the last one is when he like freezes
time and he can calculate [ __ ] right
that's the robert downey one but i'm
talking about it benedict cumberbatch is
a tv show with the dude from the hobbit
well dude there's another one with like
lucy lou and she was like sherlock
holmes so i don't know where the going
what she was sherlock holmes
who she went she was she was watson or
something i don't know i'm sure it
wasn't lucy lawless
[Laughter]
didn't they make a show with like his
daughter like enola holmes yes yes yes
that one that's that was a netflix movie
that's whatever with the stranger things
girls girl oh
you know why because it's free
anybody can make it sherlock holmes
anything we can make a [ __ ] look
because we should
i think it's over i think it's like it's
that old it's that old yeah oh [ __ ] it's
like peter pan
homes thing
there you go yeah i like that idea it's
not bad yeah i'll call it sherlock
holmes oh that's sick sherlock holmes
that's sick because it takes place
yeah takes place in paramount featuring
tim yeah sherlock holmes all right so uh
last november the area was declared a
site of special interest
due to its variety of wildlife natural
england has said more than 1700
invertebrate species called the area
home including a quarter of the uk's
water beetles nature loving group saves
swan
peninsula urged the bbc to rethink its
support of the park and following the
pressure from campaigners bbc and itv
have both now announced they are no
longer in commercial [ __ ] these animal
lovers
[Laughter]
jeez spider holy [ __ ] gives a [ __ ] about
spiders if it was a cute little like
rat or like a gerbil a cute little rat
then it's like let's save
like these minks spiders are in right
now though you know tom holland you know
this is what it looks like
man [ __ ] that guy
he a little guy
that was like those like those are
pretty big like i don't know is that
small
it looks kind of small it does you don't
i don't like spiders yeah i don't like
spiders either i think they should be
blowtorch i like spiders
i don't like spiders do we need this
specific spider to live i don't think so
i don't know but actually spiders are
are pretty helpful in the ecosystem
because they they actually take care of
a lot of the pests and bugs oh shut the
[ __ ] up
do you play with spiders do you and you
guys play with spiders yeah this guy
this guy does probably i think
mosquitoes
[Laughter]
mosquitoes and spiders are the two
things that need to die
mosquitoes yes spiders know dude if
spiders if mosquitoes left the planet i
firmly believe everybody would have the
planet can you [ __ ] imagine this
gonna be good
but spiders i think if spiders left the
planet uh a lot of ecosystems would get
[ __ ] all right you're right yes outer
space would get [ __ ] because i don't
kill spiders we set them out there dude
when i see a spider i don't kill it
i leave it in the house unless it's a
black widow then i stop the [ __ ] out of
it i kill every spider bro you do i
don't discriminate i kill it but what if
you want do you want bugs in your house
because they eat the bugs but remember i
don't want spiders either are also one
of those things that the bigger they are
the less uh poisonous or or dangerous
they are like daddy long legs apparently
are the ones that are very common those
are super poisonous but they're super
small so they don't really affect us but
they got a weak ass teeth so they can't
but they can't kill us so it's actually
the big ones that are like they look
crazy and scary but they're like less uh
dangerous
dude thank you thanks spider guy anthony
i like tarantulas
spider-man dude
i feel like tarantulas are like the
puppies would you kill a tarantula if
you just found it walk around nah i
don't kill spiders i told you you were
you're the spider killer you would kill
a tarantula i wouldn't kill a tarantula
or scary why wouldn't you kill a
tarantula if you're such a
spider-killing guy yeah actually i'll
[ __ ] kill it
stop backtracking dude
you wouldn't put in like a jar or some
[ __ ] i think it's like the mess that it
creates because they're they're so like
if you stomp on it it's just gonna
yeah that makes me cringe a little bit i
don't want that i would just have like a
little a little mess you could just wipe
up one time yeah yeah get the vacuum
killing seasonal beetles like sometimes
they're so big and crunchy it just makes
a mess
seasonal beetles yeah you know when they
get big in that time of the year oh yeah
yeah yeah they get all fat and like june
bugs are shelled well you kill a lot of
bugs huh dude i'm out there doing work
bro
i'm doing god's work what's like the
number one bug genocide that you've
committed like most genocide
[ __ ] probably like a whole hive like
a like a beehive like a hornet nest oh
[ __ ] hornets oh yeah that's pretty bad
right how'd you do that bro little
honeycomb looking shits that are in the
corner of the fight with us you know
what they're on medicine you take like a
jar of honey and then you make them like
drowning it
no i just i just hosed that [ __ ] down
and then just [ __ ] ran
how come i never spraying fire oh my god
like [ __ ] arachnophobia have you guys
seen a beehive i've never seen a beehive
oh like a traditional like winnie the
pooh looking one
i've seen a beehive i didn't is that
accurate is that screen accurate that
they look like that yeah did they dangle
no they always look [ __ ] up kind of
they look really demented but nobody
wants to draw them domestic look like
the [ __ ] cheese danish that they have
in cartoons no unfortunately what did
you do to it
you just looked at it left the [ __ ]
alone i'm not an idiot
that's what i did because i'm curious uh
i don't care if there's honey that's one
thing i don't kill bees
well i wouldn't kill a bee i just want
to steal its honey
like
you could just buy it no but it's it's
different when you oh steal it
the thrill of the
the kill of the freedom ryan's [ __ ]
creepy huh he'd be killing bugs i have
one rule
i will not kill bees
but all spiders but all other living
things
you killed
though [ __ ]
on a dare this fool goes i'll kill a
spider you know what i wanted to try
though is i wanted to try eating a
spider in southeast asia they make like
it's like it looks like soft shell crab
the way that they do
and it looked really good i think it was
android what's the type of spider they
eat
it looks like a big ass spider yeah is
it straight up tarantula it looks like a
tarantula yeah but they [ __ ] find it
in holes on the
ground it looks kind of tasty to me yes
and i want to try it i cannot
no my mental fortitude isn't that strong
do you eat some crazy [ __ ] when you're
in thailand no
wow
raw beef and that's not even that crazy
i
did not like it
raw beef that's crazy to you yeah it's
just nasty really
i took you for a adventurous man oh no
now when it comes to food no i don't
really i don't even like what do you eat
hamburgers
do you have a sensitive stomach hot dog
in thailand i don't have i don't have a
sensitive stomach i just don't like i
guess the texture in my mouth
i don't like i don't like raw fish raw
in general yeah what do you eat i'm so
curious
um your parents raised you funny there
are other things you know like what a
bowl of rice dogs and a bowl of rice
because my friend uh he uh he doesn't
like rice
because he says it reminds them of
maggots
so he only likes sandwiches do you think
there's some trauma they'll relate any
food to something gross though i feel
like there are more maggots and
sandwiches than rice
maybe you're right but for him he
doesn't eat rice he only eats sandwiches
but there are weird people who are like
i don't eat white creams and i'm like
what the hell yeah i know people like
that i'm like you're home
bro
creeps is that a racial thing i don't
know
i think so i think so i think that's
where it stems from really
no absolutely not so what is your day
go-to food what do you like to eat um
i like chicken
oh i [ __ ] love chicken what's your
favorite like fried chicken fried
chicken oh fried chicken it's so good
it's like that's like my favorite your
favorite fried chicken franchise kfc is
my favorite product
kfc
like original recipe that's just that's
my favorite
it's a nostalgic thing i'm guessing i
think it's awesome no but it [ __ ]
tastes good it's good very juicy [ __ ]
good yeah it's a juicy chicken the hater
for kfc is nuts in here it's nuts in
here i love kfc people don't like kfc
who hates kids but if there is a choice
his pompous [ __ ] so he doesn't like
it
i eat everything dude bart would say
chicken's the best bart's wrong
bart says terrible's coffee is the best
exactly thank you bart's wrong have you
guys had louisiana's style fried chicken
though you can only get it in the hood
where there's bulletproof glass and if
they don't have bulletproof glass it's
not a louisiana style it's not as good
they're all relatives and they all own
it so if you go into a franchise that's
louisiana fried chicken it's probably
they're all chinese cambodias that are
related don't bring your gun because
it's bulletproof glass you can't shoot
through it don't even need it it's like
a bank
it kind of is so the way they give you
the chicken
they give you like i think it's the
chains in l.a right it's it's there's
one in pasadena there's one there's like
two in south central there's like yeah
they're but it's usually combined too
like they got a donut shop or like a
chinese restaurant right next to it like
it's like a it's like was it fried
chicken and donuts fried chicken and
chinese food like that's the best combo
is that franchise made by cambodians no
it was like i bought like he was a guy
from texas
and then so nobody's from louisiana and
this sir no but it's kind of like how
the cambodians got into donuts you know
or like the vietnamese got into nails
like it started with an old franchise
and it just so happened where they got
all their friends together family like
hooked it up yeah and then they kept
like buying franchises for each other
you know like the indians got the
7-elevens damn so at the koreans got the
wig shops at the root of it all it's not
even a louisiana guy nope interesting i
think he was texan
i made i might have made that up i'm
always proud of us for going to fried
chicken from spiders you know
colonel sanders was cambodian
that's the yeah the original spices
spicy
sanders they're actually cambodian spicy
sanders
people don't know that it's common
misconception people are wrong
[Music]
do